me comprometo a defender nuestra capital
y a defender el país esto me obliga a
declarar el estado de excepción en
pichincha imbabura y cotopaxi a partir
de la medianoche de hoy de esta forma el
presidente de ecuador guillermo lasso
trata de apaciguar los ánimos tras más
de cinco días de protestas indígenas el
estado de excepción tendrá 30 días de
duración en los que se movilizarán a las
fuerzas armadas si suspenden los
derechos de asociación y reunión además
de la imposición de un toque de queda
nocturno en quito la capital la aso dio
a conocer además otras disposiciones
para frenar el descontento social tales
como el incremento del valor del bono de
desarrollo humano de 50 a 55 dólares la
condonación de créditos vencidos de
hasta tres mil dólares en el banco
estatal de desarrollo el subsidio a los
medianos agricultores de la mitad del
costo de laure a un fertilizante
necesario para la producción y la
congelación del precio de las gasolinas
una de las principales demandas de los
manifestantes
el mandatario hizo un llamado al diálogo
convocando a todos los sectores de la
sociedad el líder de las movilizaciones
leonidas iza saludó las medidas
económicas anunciadas desde el palacio
de carondelet pero enfatizó que las
movilizaciones continuarían ratificamos
la lucha a nivel nacional ratificamos la
lucha de manera indefinida y ratificamos
la lucha en este caso a nivel
territorial pero también desde este
momento preparamos la movilización en la
ciudad de equipo
las protestas en ecuador comenzaron el
pasado lunes con el cierre de las
carreteras por parte de la confederación
indígena a la que se han ido sumando
otras organizaciones